[Music]
Rihanna and ASAP Rocky's son celebrates
his first Easter amazing he's a happy
baby yeah the 10 month old whose name
has yet to be revealed looks real hoppy
in these sweet snaps shared by the
singer check out baby boy blinged out
for the occasion rocking a diamond
necklace
and we can't help but notice the little
guy's expression which looks exactly
like his mama's fun and you feel sassy I
mean all those things are the
ingredients that make me and fans know
rereads the queen of memeable faces
okay
clearly the Apple didn't fall far from
the tree like mother like son what is
the best part about motherhood right now
Rihanna oh my God the mornings just like
seeing his morning face and you know
like seeing a baby with like little bags
and waking up and they're just like
startled they're trying to figure out
where they at is the cutest is my
favorite part of the day but ree's son
is involved in her whole day even Mama's
precious hour of fitness
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
earlier this month re-shared that clip
of the little one interrupting her sweat
sesh with the caption look who don't
want Mommy to work out it's all an
exciting Journey so far I'm just taking
it as it comes and later this year
riri's Journey will continue as a mom of
two your shoes
[Music]
when you become a mom there's something
that just happens where you feel like
you could take on the world yeah before
re revealed she's pregnant with baby
number two during the Super Bowl
halftime show E.T scored insight into
how the couple feels about growing their
family A source told ET in January the
Grammy winner adores being a mom calling
it her biggest accomplishment they've
been talking about expanding their
family for quite some time being a mom
is a dream come true for Rihanna she
takes so much pride in it I'm still
pinching myself really I'm grateful well
we predict more excellent times ahead
with Riri and her growing family
[Music]
foreign